[Music]
you're looking at a behind-the-scenes
rehearsal for the new Robin Hood movie
but it's for more than just the stop
performers not only are they using this
rehearsal to map out who will kick what
when or where the camera will move at
any given moment
they're intricately mapping out a rough
idea of how everything down to this
special effects and CGI will look in the
final film it's a process called
pre-visualization and it's a crucial
part of a lot of Hollywood movies but
just how does this hidden part of the
process work here stunt performers are
playing out the fight sequence for
Robins Treasury heist one of the most
pivotal and action-packed scenes in the
movie the stakes were high for planning
this beyond his career as a stunt double
for actors like Brad Pitt and Christian
Bale Dom has coordinated stunts for
movies like atomic blonde and TV shows
like The Borgias I just and coordinates
are obviously very closely together in
pretty much every department my job on a
film like Robin Hood is basically to
reaction choreographed action set-pieces
staged them errors them and then once we
get to shoot it make sure that we are
shooting it in an effective way when
planning a major action scene like this
one most of the heavy lifting happens
before filming has even begun the first
step is designing exactly how the fight
will go down when you make you know if
I'd seen the obviously you have to
understand why the fight is happening
where it's happening in the story for
the location the set you have to
understand for the tone is because
they're gonna dictate the style because
at the beginning of the process it
wasn't decided yet if this fight scene
was really dark and brutal fight or a
bit more lighthearted and follow and
comedy like I was really happy with with
the final decision which which basically
was that we made his fight a little more
lighthearted but the most important was
the mood of it once you have the full
understanding of that and
directions from the director you
obviously start to choreograph that's
going to take you the process of putting
a live-action babies together
pre-visualization or previous for sure
is a tool used during pre-production
that involves mapping out complex action
scenes to see what they look like on
camera we're basically taking a floor
plans of the set we build the replica
set on a rehearsal stage using the same
dimensions we shoe it we edited roughly
once there is a final ready we show the
director and the CGI in the previous is
pretty crude but the director can use
this as a screen test to identify and
adjust accordingly after seeing the
previs the director might revise the
choreography in part of the fight or
just scrap that part altogether
ultimately the Robin Hood treasury scene
got trimmed down almost in half which
could then be spent on other parts of
the movie the length and intensity of
the treasury scene reflect its
importance in the plot and to the movie
on a whole
he's fighting many opponents in ways
which we never see in the Robin fight
before not only shooting the arrow
versus using the bow to hand-to-hand
combat in this reboot gives us a darker
and grittier version of Robin Hood than
we've seen before the legendary outlaw
is shown as a war hardened fighter who
pulls off rapid fire arrow stunts and
has a combat style inspired by John wick
my two favorite moments in the fight is
one is the baseball slide which I'm not
going to explain in detail what it is
because people should watch it the other
one is when Robin has not got a floor
and his is on his back
getting approached by a buddy and the
only way he can shoot an arrow is by
grabbing hold of the ball with his feet
pulling the string to Mercy let go to me
those two moments are the essence of
this fight and explain that this Robin
is classic Roman hood but thus things
using his signature weapon which he
hasn't done before I think they say in
really is giving this Robin its own
legacy
[Music]